but rather we're really interested in is
this one at the top right so even though
there is a write a good train which sort
of calculates it this is the one unreal
in here which you can see is not right
angle okay but you can use right angled
triangle tree which is really the
trigonometry of all triangles to get
toward that triangle right so the simple
question they posed for you is just find
X okay ah this is interesting because
there's an intermediate length I have to
work out this length down here how do I
work it out what am I going to use I'm
going to use ten I don't write because
I've got an angle here I have its
adjacent side known and the opposite
side is what's under okay so if I just
sort of quickly label this is why you
buddy the equation that you would write
P is well topping what would you what
statement would you make about this
triangle down here involving ten Tommy
that's all right
ten thirty good opposite on adjacent
okay now 10:30 that's an exact angle
zero 30 45 60 and 90 you've got exact
angles for all of them and the quickest
way if you think back to a couple of a
weekly cricket quizzes ago the quickest
way to remember what they are is just to
draw up your triangle okay in fact I'm
going to encourage you whenever you've
got a test that's going to involve
trigonometry the first thing you should
do is draw this pair of triangles okay
you only need to know very very little
information in order to do these if I
make this a 30-60-90 triangle okay the
easiest trig ratio the easiest exact
trig ratio to remember is same day which
is 1/2 good scyther
means opposite over hypotenuse one on
two right and then pythagoras or by
memory you can work out that that's root
three okay so from there I have all the
ratios side caused a tear for 30 60 etc
write this one down here is the same
triangle but isosceles so find this one
and one that would make the hypotenuse
and because it's isosceles you've got
these 45 angles here
okay yeah yeah all pass an exercise so
it's a bit different okay so I always
like I've mentally do this there are
some other tricks which I might show you
throughout the course of our triple
period to remember these but I think
this is probably the most efficient it's
not the most glamorous but it worked
okay so I'm after 1030 in this case
right 1030
so where's 1030 there's thirty right so
opposite on adjacent yeah happy with
that so that's going to be 103 why
Holland's ten yep so far so good
so now just by taking that equation all
I need to say and multiply both sides by
10 and now I have this distance okay so
now where do I go whoops where do I go
from there
okay so now I've got the bigger triangle
right which is an angle of 60 in there
and I'm going to make the same statement
1060 is still opposite or adjacent right
but this time I've got two natural ends
here okay yeah looking good
so it's 1060 again look at straggles
1060 1060 have a look
opposite on adjacent right opposite
colonization to through three equals x
plus 10 root three now just to save
myself a step rather than write that ten
or the denominator I'm going to multiply
across something to do it eventually
anyhow yep so now I've got x equals ten
root three by this head-on
retreat yep suggestion which I do next
I had a couple different choices I could
rationalize first right or I know for my
head I like to get one fraction first
you're going to get the same answer in
email so here I'm going to multiply by
it root 303 so that gives you 30 on root
3
you're happy with that - 10 because I
have the same denominator don't know so
now it gives me 20 on root 3 and now
I'll just nationalize done okay so up in
this triangle here if that's all I had
we can determine what this length is and
you know just to play a hypothetical if
I you know took away this triangle down
here if I hide asleep I could still work
out what the lit was